Hey everyone, 2020 has been quite the year, hasn't it?
Definitely one of those for the history books.
So over on Talk Python to me,
I did a year in review show,
and it actually had me and Brian on there,
along with a bunch of other really great guests
who have been on this show and on Talk Python before.
So I thought what we could do for our year in review here
is to bring you that same show,
to bring you that same conversation.
In fact, it was more in the style of Python Bytes
than it was Talk Python, to be honest.
So I think it belongs here.
So without further ado, let's join that conversation where we look back on 2020
with Cecil Phillip, Enos Montani, Jay Miller, Paul Everett, Reuben Lerner, Matt
Harrison, Brian Auken, and me.
Enjoy the show and thank you so much for listening to Python Bytes this year.
We'll see you in 2021.
So let's go ahead and just kick off this episode.
This one is a little bit different than the standard show.
Everyone here has been a guest and a great guest, and some of you even repeat guests.
Some of you are repeat guests and scheduled for more episodes, even hint and Enos,
but let's go ahead and kick it off.
So this is going to be a year in review.
There's a bunch of us here, seven or eight of us.
And I'll just do a quick introduction.
Let me just welcome you individually on.
You could say, you know, a couple of sentences about who you are and whatnot.
So people know, and then we're just going to get into what you thought was the most
interesting, impactful thing of the year.
And I have some software to help me do this.
So let me run it here.
Darn it.
It's me.
All right.
We'll go back to that.
Well, let me welcome you all.
Then we'll go through this.
So Jay, Jay Miller, welcome to talk by the name again.
Happy to be here.
I haven't been a guest in like three years.
So I know, but your episode was so popular, like over a hundred
thousand people listened to your episode.
Can you believe that?
That's so insane.
I'm shutting down my podcast.
I don't get those kinds of lessons.
Tell people about yourself.
Sure.
Jay Miller.
I'm a podcaster developer now developer advocate for elastic, you
you know, the people that do search.
And we are database shots again, Michael.
But yeah, I'm just happy to be here.
Yeah, that's it.
- Awesome, welcome.
Ruven Lerner, welcome back.
Good to see you, man.
- Hey there, nice to be here.
- How early is it?
- It's not that early, it's only 5.30.
- Oh, okay, well thank you so much for waking up early.
Yeah, we have people from basically
every corner of the world, so yeah.
Tell people about yourself,
again, if they haven't heard the episodes.
- Sure, so I'm a Python trainer.
So most days I'm in different companies
doing on-site training.
Nowadays a little less on-site for some strange reason.
And so I normally do corporate training,
everything from intro to Python for non-programmers
all the way up to advanced Python workshops.
And I also sell a whole bunch of courses online
to individuals.
Oh, and I have my book, my book, Python Workout.
Yay, Python Workout.
- Yeah, and we're streaming live with video,
so you can hold it up, yeah, that's awesome.
- Oh, I can hold it up.
- Python Workout, awesome.
- And this is a picture of me on the cover, of course.
- Of course, yeah.
- That was when you were working out,
preparing for the Olympics?
- Precisely, precisely.
- Yeah, exactly.
So we'll be sure to link to your book
and some of your courses as well.
Ines, welcome from the other side of the world.
- Yeah, I'm currently in Australia,
escaped the EU lockdowns and now I'm here.
Yeah, happy to be back.
I think I've been on a few of your podcasts,
but it's always my favorite podcasts.
- Oh, thank you.
Yeah, it's awesome to have you here.
And I have definitely dreamed about,
well, my daughter goes to school online.
I always work online.
Maybe we should just go somewhere by a beach,
away from people.
How could we do that where it's warm, right?
And it seems like you pulled it off.
Beautiful.
All right, Paul Everett, welcome.
- I just saw Anthony Shaw talking,
so if you want to talk about converting your life
to work at the beach,
just subscribe to his damn Twitter account.
- Welcome, Anthony Shaw.
- Anthony, I'm raging against you.
- Oh my gosh, also from Australia.
Hey, Anthony.
And Andrew from PyCharm is here,
a bunch of folks.
Mark, awesome.
Paul, introduce yourself.
- Sure.
I'm an advocate at JetBrains for Python stuff and web stuff.
Most known for giving the Python 1994 talk.
My purpose on this panel is to increase the median age
so that we all qualify for the discount at the buffet.
Hey man, I'm right there with you.
Right there with you, awesome.
Nice to have you, Paul.
Brian, we've met before, right?
Yeah.
Brian Aukin, he and I co-host Python Bytes Together.
And you've been on the show quite a few times as well.
Last time, I think we covered 30 pytest plugins.
That was quite the whirlwind tour.
Yeah, so I highly recommend this book to anybody that wants to learn pytest.
Awesome. Matt Harrison, welcome back.
Thanks. Good to be here. I guess I'm similar to Reuben. I do corporate training and consulting
in Python and data science. And I guess since we're flaunting books, I'll flaunt my latest book.
Wait, wait, the tiny Python 3 notebook.
Tiny Python notebook. It's very small. Anyway.
It is tiny. Well, what I was going to say, Matt, is like, you're going to need to be like,
basically an octopus to hold up all your books. Like multiple books on each tentacle.
I've got a few here. So yeah, it's good to be here. Thanks for having me on.
Yeah, you were just recently on about learning how to learn.
Yeah.
Does it count if I have everyone else's book?
Yes, it does. But it will also be hard to hold them all up, especially if you got all of them.
Cecil, hello, man. Hello. Good to see you, friend.
Hey, thanks for having me on. I don't have any books to share.
But because I hate writing, so I don't write anything. I do do some video.
So if you're interested, I do do a weekly Python stream on Wednesdays.
So if you folks want to check it out, it's on Twitch
on the Microsoft developer account.
And we do very beginner friendly conversations
about Python and stuff like that.
And Michael, you were just on the other day too, right?
- Yeah, it was so fun to be on there with you.
We got to play around with FastAPI
and man, that's a cool framework.
- So it's Coding From The Beach.
What's the name of the show?
- That's a good name, actually.
Maybe I should coin that one.
No, so we do PyWeekly.
So it's me and my co-worker, Brian Clark.
And we kind of approach Python
from the perspective of beginners,
but also from two people that don't necessarily
know Python very well.
So, you know, Brian is a JavaScript guy,
I'm a .NET guy, but we're both,
I like to call it Py-curious, you know what I mean?
Like we're Python curious.
And, you know, we definitely want to show people
like the different perspectives of learning
like new languages.
- Yeah, it's super interesting.
And it is really low-key.
It's like you said, it's this Twitch
sort of exploration style of code,
not polished presentation style.
So you just guys sit down,
take feedback from the audiences,
and go with it.
- Yeah, I love this show, 'cause I'm never prepared.
Like, I kinda just show up and talk about stuff,
and people love it, and it's great.
I don't have to do notes or anything like that.
We just kinda be like,
"Hey, what do we wanna learn about today?"
Right, well, let's go ahead and do it.
- Yeah, fantastic.
All right, well, given how many of us there are,
let's go ahead and just jump in,
and we're gonna do our year in review.
And so I've written a small piece of Python software
here in the REPL.
It's very advanced.
It's at least four lines of code, I gotta tell you.
And what it's gonna do is it's gonna pick one of you,
And then we're going to have you talk about what you felt was the most
significant or impactful thing that you saw happening in the Python space.
So round one, Cecil, you're on screen and it pulled you up.
Go for it.
Wow, I got lucky.
Okay.
So the most exciting thing that, that I think happened in the world of Python
on one that I have a little bit of a close relationship to is the fact that
Guido van Rossum joined Microsoft just a couple of weeks ago.
So I didn't mention this before, but I do work at Microsoft as a
developer advocate. And I think for me, it's been a really interesting to kind of see how
the company has, you know, been embracing open source and working with a lot of the
creators and now seeing a lot of the leaders of the industry kind of joined the company.
You know what I mean? It kind of, you know, it's a kind of, it's like a different world.
I mean, I don't know how else to explain it or, or talk about it. It's been really great
to have him here. I had the opportunity actually to interview him. And we did like an internal
interview just talking about like, well, what made you decide to come on a retirement?
That's awesome. Was this on channel nine? Is it public or is it?
No, it was internal. It was an internal interview. I don't know what his, his,
I know I'm sure he will do some other ones, but it was an internal one.
Did you make him whiteboard?
No, we didn't do him any whiteboarding. We did ask him what some of his favorite shows were. So
that was, that was pretty interesting. We asked him like the Star Trek versus Star Wars conversation
too.
I couldn't, I couldn't handle that pressure.
It's hard, man. It's a tough crowd.
I think it's definitely amazing to be able to see folks from the industry
embracing these different companies and us really supporting open source in a very authentic way.
Yeah, it's such a big change.
Reuven, you were just talking before we started streaming, I think,
about 10 years ago, how this was really different.
Oh, yeah. I mean, even more. But yeah, even 10 years ago,
the notion that Microsoft would be so involved in the open source space,
and specifically the Python space was basically unthinkable. I mean, I think it was Steve Ballmer who said that, you know, Microsoft, not Microsoft, like the Linux and open source were a cancer on the industry.
And they were definitely seen, you know, Microsoft was seen as an enemy of the open source world.
And it's been truly amazing to see them just embrace it. I mean, you see the booth at Python, you see the VS code investment.
It's very, very impressive. And it demonstrates, and he says, we'll say this earlier, like,
how much leadership at the top really can change the direction and the attitude of a company,
and that filters through to even the lower level people and the decisions made there.
Yeah, that's a lot of hard work, right? Because if you think about it,
we've had different leadership for a very long time. And so for some of us,
some of this change that people are still recognizing, I mean, we've been doing it for a very long time.
You know what I mean? Like we didn't just in 2020 decide, oh, hey, let's adopt and support open source.
It's been one of those things that have been building very much over time.
But the fact of the matter is, you still have those old stigmas that we still have to shake,
and we still have a lot of folks that we have to help convince that we're not the Death Star,
and we won't destroy the world kind of thing.
But I think it's a good responsibility to take on, because there's also a lot to fuck up.
And if you commit to doing something, like GitHub acquisition,
and say, "Okay, we're doing that and we're running it."
You know, we're good sign forward
because every misstep can have like,
you know, a really big impact.
- Yeah.
- You know, if Microsoft starts doing bad things again,
people are not gonna be, you know,
they forgiving at all.
So.
- I think that was the most sensitive,
one of them all is the GitHub acquisition
because what they do to Azure is kind of their story.
What they do to Windows is their story,
but what they do to GitHub, that's everyone's story.
And all of a sudden, that was a big deal.
- Yeah.
- And on top of that, you had the ability
to give GitHub a little bit more power in the space.
Like, I mean, we've all been kind of watching what's happening
with like YouTube DL and stuff like that.
And just seeing the support, it's not just GitHub anymore now.
It's like, OK, what does one of the the wealthiest companies in the world,
you know, say about this particular position that YouTubers have a problem
with, that people in tech have a problem with, like a lot of abusive behavior?
And on top of that, you're providing support for things like NPM.
It's one of those questions.
We all want to contribute to open source, but none of us have the financial
ability to contribute like a company like Microsoft can.
So I'm not just saying we're going to be a part of it, but saying, no, we're
really going to be a part of it is like a huge deal.
Yeah.
The million dollar defense fund that they just announced is a big deal.
Yeah, for sure.
And when you think about GitHub, right?
Like you think about like developer culture, that's what
GitHub kind of represents to me.
is the new, you know, the future of developer culture.
Like, how do we collaborate? How do we work with each other?
How do we share not just source code, but like,
experiences and knowledge, right, through, like, something that we can all connect together with?
That's code, right?
And then kind of circling it back around to Guido,
being able to, again, see these leaders of these really large open source projects
put their faith in the company,
and even considering what the past of the company was to what it is today,
I think hopefully like the rest of the open source world would start to realize that we are serious about
being good open source citizens and supporting the culture in the community.
I mean, me personally, I'm just really excited to see what he's going to do what he's going to work on.
The future is bright, man.
Yeah, absolutely.
I think someone on on Twitter had said, so now we actually hire folks that contributes to,
you know, obviously C# and F sharp and dotnet stuff, but also folks that contribute to Java,
Rust, C++, and now obviously Python, right? So we have a whole host of language folks
underneath the umbrella of the company. And so now being able to have that space of collaboration,
like underneath the umbrella of one company, I think is going to be really interesting to see
what the next couple of years looks like. Yeah, you have to come back in six months
and give us an update on all the Python changes. I'll give you a six month update on it.
This episode is brought to you by Linode. Simplify your infrastructure and cut your
cloud builds in half with Linode's Linux virtual machines. Develop, deploy, and scale your modern
applications faster and easier. Whether you're developing a personal project or managing larger
workloads, you deserve simple, affordable, and accessible cloud computing solutions.
As listeners of PythonBytes, you'll get $100 free credit. You can find all the details at
pythonbytes.fm/linode. Linode has data centers all around the world with the same simple and
and consistent pricing regardless of location.
Choose the data center that's nearest to you and your users.
You'll receive 24/7/365 human support
with no tiers or handoffs regardless of your plan size.
You can choose shared or dedicated compute instances,
or you can use your $100 in credit
on the S3 compatible object storage,
managed Kubernetes clusters, and more.
If it runs on Linux, it runs on Linode.
Visit pythonbytes.fm/linode
and click that create free account button to get started.
All right, I'm going to run the chooser.
Paul, it has chosen you.
Not sure about your chooser algorithm here.
It doesn't seem to be...
Random dot choice, I'm telling you.
This time it's not a good time to talk about election strategies.
And it's seen as how it chose you first.
It could be flawed.
Are you changing the random seat on every...
Exactly.
Yeah, I should be. I'm not.
My topic is "Things change, nothing changes."
And I think I'm maybe stealing someone else's topic,
so I appreciate your random algorithm choosing me first.
And it's kind of along the lines, I'm kind of interested in open source communities
over the years and decades and why one works, why one doesn't.
In particular, a lot of open source projects that get successful
kind of founder when the founder leaves.
And over the last couple of years, you've seen Guido transition out,
Stepping out as BDFL and kind of a new language governance model that he didn't even decide on.
He let it emerge.
And then new release managers, new PSF directors, all happening this year.
A pandemic, which kind of destroyed the big fundraiser,
an organizing event called PyCon,
Python 2.7 end of life,
which I guess a lot of us thought would never effing happen,
and it effing happened.
And it threw all of this change for a project that was like reaching mega escape velocity and popularity
Nothing changed. Everyone's like who cares python just kept on doing the doing its business releases kept cranking out peps kept cranking out
Elections well python elections kept cranking out
Michael and brian kept cranking out podcasts
Hallelujah something good happened in 2020
And so it's interesting to me, healthy projects are those with a healthy bench,
kind of a middle management.
Python has a hell of a middle management now. It's awesome.
And it's like middle management in every vector now.
It's got language leadership, middle management,
foundation leadership, middle management,
conferences, all the regional conferences are kicking ass, even online.
So it's really good for me to see a balance between some of the old heroes
like Brett Cannon who gave this awesome keynote
two or three or four years ago
at PyCon about open source.
And then some of the new heroes like Marlene Mangami.
When I give the Python 1994 talk,
sometimes I give it with Barry.
And it's like,
"Well, did you ever know back then that it was gonna..."
Hell no, we didn't know.
And so seeing all of this happen,
seeing generation after generation come in,
do their thing, raise the next generation,
is pretty cool to see.
Yeah, it's fantastic.
And I know there was a lot of uncertainty
when Guido stepped down about,
oh my gosh, what's going to happen?
But it's kind of been a non-issue, which is good.
Non-issue in a good way.
- Indeed.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I think it's really nice to also have,
you know, some stability, even, you know,
especially nowadays that's quite rare.
And just to see, you know, stuff just works.
Nothing goes wrong, no drama, no, you know,
nothing terrible, just drums, almost boring.
- Yeah, boring's good these days.
One of the things that really surprises me,
Paul, as you mentioned, the escape velocity.
What's weird to me is how Python went like 20 years on medium, like simmer popularity,
and then it hit the afterburners and took off.
Right? It seems just, I think there's going to be some interesting studies done about
why or how did a language that had kind of been around for 20 years all of a sudden
really dramatically improve in popularity.
I have some ideas, but I just think that that's an interesting aspect of what you're talking about here.
Yeah, it's also the whole aspect of the, you know, the previous like Microsoft and Java
and sort of, I guess, big money behind those sorts of languages and like the early 2000s pushing them.
And then I think community and to the point of like developer gave developers what they wanted,
rather than maybe say enterprise-y languages.
And then I think there's a whole confluence of other things that happened as well.
But it is kind of crazy, right? That like one of the top, if not the top languages right now,
They're almost 30 years old.
And it's got issues, it's got warts and whatnot,
but it's a thriving language.
And without significant big companies behind it,
that it's competing with companies
that have thrown millions of dollars
into development of these things.
- Yeah, absolutely.
And Matt and Enos, you two are on the data science side.
And I think the data science and computational folks
are the ones that poured the gas on the fire
and really made it take off.
And that's not where the growth necessarily completely is,
but I think that gave it a serious kick.
- Yeah, no, actually, because I get asked about this a lot,
like, oh, what do you think made Python the language
for machine learning data science?
And my theory is actually that,
A, Python, of course, was lucky
that it was in the right place at the right time,
but I think actually it won
because it's a general purpose language.
People can come from other fields of Python
into machine learning data science, for example.
Like, what did people do before?
If you look at kind of these surveys
of what to use Python for,
before it's a lot of web stuff.
You can build kind of anything in Python.
And I think that's what makes it so appealing and much more appealing than, let's say,
like an AI language.
And that's also, in my opinion, why a lot of these attempts at making an AI language
haven't taken off.
And people are like, "No, Python's great."
It's fast enough.
It's usable enough.
But I think the general purpose is really what kind of got it over the edge there.
And a lot of people that I'm teaching or training are people who don't want to be programmers.
They want to use Python as a tool.
It's like Excel to them.
They don't want to be programmers.
And so something that they can pick up and it just sort of works and they can go to Stack
Overflow and copy something.
And as long as they get the indentation right, it sort of works as long as they're using
the right version or whatever.
There's no compiling.
There's no linking.
Yeah.
Weirdness.
And then you have things like Google Colab or whatever, where you have an environment
that's all set up and you can just sort of go right.
And so that is really empowering for people who don't want to be programmers, but view
Python as a tool, a necessary tool that they need to leverage.
And in addition, there's over a quarter of a million packages on PyPI, right?
And that's like literally standing on the shoulders of giants.
You can go there and pick out something that you want to do, and you're a pip install away
from it.
And that's super powerful, right?
You don't have to set up a huge environment.
Yeah, it just really simplifies life for a lot of these people
who don't want to be programmers but want to leverage these really cool, bleeding-edge...
But at the same time, you do have very strong support for C extensions.
So if you're looking at the top packages people download from PyPy,
most of them are written in C, Cython, whatever.
That's what makes them so powerful.
So we have that while also being able to provide a pretty good developer experience.
Yeah, absolutely.
I think it was Seymour Papper who talked about a good language having,
he was talking about Logo, but it's even more appropriate for Python,
having low floors and high ceiling.
That's really easy to get in and do simple stuff,
but when you want to do complex stuff, you're not limited.
And so just yesterday I was doing a workshop with people,
and someone who had just started with Python,
I said, "Oh, but look what we can do if we extend it several layers."
And he was amazed how complex you can get
and how sophisticated you can get just in a few lines of code.
It's really a testament to the elegance of the design of the language, I think.
Andre Vlasovsky in the chat makes a good point that many folks say Python is their second favorite language.
And there's something to be said for that.
Dierks, sorry, should be there first.
I'm with you.
Well, to that point, I mean, it's also been said that Python is the second best language for doing things right.
So you might have a language that's better.
That's actually his quote, I got it right.
or you might have a language that's better for web apps,
you might have a language that's better for system admin,
but there's probably not a language that's going to get you all three of those, right?
And Python is sort of that Venn diagram that gets you in the middle
and is good enough to do a lot of what you want to do.
Absolutely. Random by choice, chooses Brian Auken.
Well, hey, cool. Let me pull up my notes.
It was interesting, we were talking about Microsoft,
and I didn't choose this, but I'm going to mention it anyway.
tons of projects switched over to GitHub Actions in 2020.
And I mean, because it just
kind of hit the area right
like at the end of 2019.
So I saw a lot of projects migrating to GitHub Actions.
Anyway, I wanted to talk about packaging,
which is sort of related.
There's a couple things, I know I was supposed to pick one.
The exciting thing happened today, pip20.3
was released and the dependency resolver is now the default.
The dependencies resolver is already angry at me for trying to deploy some dependabot changes.
I'm excited about this and it's bit me already too. I've had requirements.txt files
that have broken dependencies. So I have to go look at those and see which, you know, I have to pay attention to it.
So there's a little bit of pain for some people, but it was such a long struggle.
I look back and the request for a dependency resolver came in 2013.
So, 7 years later.
But something magical happened in 2019,
and that was some money from Mozilla
came through and they threw some of that money at the dependency resolver.
That was pretty cool.
Yeah, that's a big deal that money was
there's been a couple of these
experiences where money was given to Python specifically to hire a team to
improve something. PyPI, the rewrite of pypi.org was one and this is another.
Yeah, and they rolled it out in several versions. So we had our version early
early in the year.
And then around July, we had another version that had a different flag that you could try it out with
to try to get some of the early adopters to try it out to make sure it's working.
And then today, it's rolled out for good. And I'm pretty excited about it.
I kind of want to tie this in with the packaging. I've seen a lot of progress on
and a lot of adoption of the PyProject.toml, kind of taking over more packages and more uses.
So we saw flit used to have its own any file now only uses PyProject.toml.
There's been additions to the metadata definition that hopefully will take hold.
And even pytest now, you can throw your configuration in a pyproject.toml.
And I've seen more and more projects saying, getting pressure from their users to say,
"I don't want another any file. I want to put my settings in the pyproject.toml."
So that's a good thing.
Yeah, absolutely.
You know, a couple of things on that. You talked about two things when you talked about packaging,
you talked about GitHub. I mean, the fact that now you can actually do some package work within GitHub
itself, I built a lot of small little tools, not things that I would want to go on PyPI. No, we
don't need to clutter that up anymore with my garbage. But it's great when I can just say like,
hey, here's a link. And if you're really, you know, concerned on how to add it, you can just
hip install but point to this GitHub, you know, and that that works.
Yeah, and also the stuff about finding security vulnerabilities automatically
and doing PRs for you that GitHub does
against like your various package definitions.
I think that's great as well.
Hey, has anybody ever put a JavaScript package
on the GitHub package.json?
Probably, but not me.
I have.
You know this is a Python podcast, right?
It's Gatsby, so I basically put 500,000 JavaScript packages into my repo.
Yeah.
And I'm saying, that is something I appreciate about Python a lot, that like, I actually,
I never thought I'd say this, but like, I do prefer also that you don't get...
I can't resolve the Dependabot security mega warnings fast enough.
It's just incredible.
I know.
And I just turn them off, right?
Like, you just don't.
That totally fixes it.
- That is one way to do it, yes.
- It's like, I've always said that's a problem
with writing tests, right?
Like when I started programming, I was all like,
kind of hate writing these tests
because they keep pointing out shit that's kind of wrong
and then I have to fix that.
But I don't have tests.
It all works fine and then I'm happy.
Same with, I don't know, TypeScript.
- Exactly.
- Or actually even TypePens to some,
fuck yeah, I know that's kind of wrong.
So now I actually have to fix it.
So, you know, just don't.
- So we should not let you speak at our high school.
It's the see no evil, hear no evil.
I do think that the Dependabot stuff,
there is something about turning it off.
It drives me crazy. I really value it.
But at the same time, the reason I had this conflict
with the dependency resolver is
it told me I should, it gave me a PR
to upgrade one thing, but not one of the dependencies
for which the newer version was required
or it would break the resolver.
It's just like, "Ah, what is this thing doing?"
Alright, very good, Brian.
The chooser is all choosing.
- You need a batch dependency resolver.
- Yes.
- One that resolves everything at once
and then makes sure you've got a working state at the end.
- Well, the thing is, the PIMP is fine.
It was right.
It's that Dependabot, if you have 100,
not 100, I probably had 20 dependencies in this thing,
it gives you one PR for each line.
It sometimes just like lags a day on the other one.
And if it gets it out of order,
then the resolver, anyway, long story, frustrating.
- I mean, to be fair, speaking of dependency resolving
from the perspective of a library developer.
It is hard, and you do want to use versioning properly.
And I do feel like there's this eternal conflict between,
how do we manage dependencies properly for users,
and how can we make sure that we can define
how our packages depend on each other
in a way that's reasonable?
Because not-- and use semantic versioning.
Not everything is a major release.
Not everything is a breaking release.
But stuff just depends on each other,
and you don't want to lock people in.
There's always this-- the idea is,
you should be able to pick up your project a year later
with its requirements and it should run.
And that's really, really, really hard.
- Yeah, and if it gets wrong,
then you probably get a lot of email
or a lot of GitHub issues.
- Hey, Brian, on your topic of PyProject TOML,
what's the latest, greatest, oneditable installs?
- I don't think it's completely working for all the same.
So I'd like to be able to say pip install -e,
is it -e?
And just a project.
You can say pip install just a directory,
no matter what kind of packager it has.
So that works now.
So you can, even if you use flit or something,
you can't do -e, but flit itself, for instance,
has its own editable install thing.
And I don't know what poetry does.
I don't use poetry.
So it's a different command.
I'm annoyed that it doesn't just convert it.
I wish it would plug it in,
but I think that'll be coming in maybe in 2020 or 20,
probably not this year, maybe next year, hopefully.
- Yeah.
Bad Wolf says in the chats,
what is a quick solution for getting pip version updated?
The first thing you create a virtual environment.
This is another thing that drives me crazy about PIP
and if that could get changed, I would love it.
When you create a new virtual environment,
basically for about a week, you have the latest PIP.
And then afterwards, soon as you pip install something,
it says, warning, your pip is out of date.
Soon as you create a virtual environment,
it's like, well, why didn't you just update it?
I want, if you're gonna tell me it's wrong, just fix it.
- You can use virtual environment.
Instead of VNV, use virtual environment
because then you can update your PIP
and you can update the global one
and install it in all your environments.
- Interesting.
Yeah, I just wrote an alias
that will create the virtual environment,
upgrade pip and set up tools,
and then activate it.
Other way around, activate it, then upgrade.
- Yeah, it's funny, I have a shortcut like that too.
- Yeah, awesome.
- And then you can also have it install everything you need,
you know, in the same command,
automatically create once,
which I shared my script somewhere,
I think on Twitter, if anyone's interested.
- Nice, yeah, mine's just v and v.
I just type v and v and magic happens.
I don't think of it anymore.
- Well, when I finally switched to virtual Linv,
it's like, I make so many virtual environments,
it's so much faster.
And just that, even just a few seconds,
several times a day, it's worth it for me.
So, I like it.
- Awesome.
All right, I've chosen next,
and there's a dependency in the chooser,
so it's worked correctly.
So it's chosen me actually,
to talk about the next thing.
And Paul touched on this,
but I think this is a really important one.
Like this is the year that Python 2 actually went away.
And it's, I just spent so long having to justify
why Python 3 is the right thing,
or more often teaching people,
no, no, no, you can't type Python, please don't do that.
Unless you're on Windows, then you have to do that.
But if you're not on Windows, then you better not do that.
So you gotta, you know, it's just like this drag,
it always felt like things like Django or Flask
and whatnot were being held back.
All these libraries were being held back
by Python 2 support.
And last year they started dropping it,
and then Python 2 itself actually went away.
Brian and I tried to create the right nomenclature
around this, I guess.
I was calling it legacy Python and modern Python
rather than two and three, and that was fun.
People started to quote it and use that terminology,
which was kind of cool.
I don't know how well it worked,
but it's really nice that Python 2
is finally officially gone.
And I thought there'd be a bunch of people
would freak out for Python
and start creating alternate old versions.
And I haven't, besides some commercial support stuff,
I really seen that happening.
So it's pretty interesting, I think.
- Yeah, I think we should have brought like horns and stuff
and like, you know, waving.
- Some of those pop, like bottle-looking
- Yeah, yeah.
- stuff on New Year's, absolutely.
Yeah, I mean, we really didn't get the party
we were hoping for, right?
Like PyCon was supposed to be this big send off
for Python 2, but no, there was not so much of a PyCon.
Not really, I mean, there's online, but it wasn't the same.
- Now we just gotta wait until we have all of the articles
about the companies that finally decided to switch
and the steps that they took
that they avoided for the last decade
to make this a reality.
One of my biggest corporate training clients,
they have been using Python 2 for years and years
and they do all sorts of testing of hardware using Windows
with all sorts of custom C extensions.
So I've been saying to them for years,
every time I do training, "Look, you should really think
Python 3 and you should realize you should move in that direction." And their attitude was basically,
"No, no, no. We've got so much invested in what we've done. We're not really going to upgrade."
And finally, about, I guess, a year ago, they realized, "Huh, we're going to be stuck on our
own maintaining everything, including all these packages of the API. Maybe it's time to start
talking about it." And so I'm actually doing some training for them now. And I asked a group,
"Should we do Python 2 or should we do Python 3?" And the majority actually said, "It's okay
can use three because our group has switched.
So if they are moving, it's clear that even sort of the
dragiest of the draggiest companies are doing it.
- Yeah, I was just gonna echo what Ruben said that,
you know, when you have success and you get enterprises
using your stuff and enterprises are slow to move.
And I don't wanna like criticize Python three too much,
but I think if they would have put f-strings in 3.0,
then they wouldn't have had this problem.
But because they waited to put f-strings in,
then they had people dragging their feet.
It's so weird how that drag, that was one of the most popular features for sure.
So you're saying the walrus operator was what finally did it?
[laughter]
I'm not gonna go there.
You know, I was not super excited about the walrus operator.
I've found myself using it all the time, I like it.
It's neat.
Oh, it's cool, I think it definitely solves a problem.
I just, wait, that's 3.8, right? The walrus?
I believe so.
Yeah, I'm still, I mean, I feel like I'm now back at like,
okay, we finally dropped support for 2 from all of our libraries that we're developing,
and now we're on 3.6, because--
- Yeah, yeah. - No, no, no.
3.9 is current, 3.8 is now the new legacy Python.
(laughing)
- Ines, how was it for you, like, as a library developer?
- Yeah, I mean, for a lot,
I feel like I only really got to use Python 3 this year.
I mean, of course, I've been using it privately
for much longer, but I would say,
in mid this year, I was finally like, cool,
I just use type hints, I use fstrings
across all of our projects, because before,
our dependencies had to support people on two.
And our old version of spaCy had to support
people who wanted to use two.
So that kind of becomes the baseline.
And now we've moved that up to 3.6.
And so until 3.6 is dead,
there's still always new features
that we can't just ship.
- Yeah, but that step from two to 3.6
is gonna be way bigger than 3.6 to seven, right?
That's a very small step,
the 3.6 to 3.7 or 3.7 to 3.8.
So you've done the big step.
- Yeah, and some of the new features,
It's like, yeah, whatever I can, you know, live without writing those in my code base
and people can still use them in their code bases.
But yeah, all the new versions we've got to publish like spacey three that's coming soon.
We'll use Python three in the code base and we'll only work with Python three.
We want distribute wheels for Python two, which we might have not even done for a while
because it's really, really a pain for some of our more abstract and complex dependencies
that we're also building.
So far people haven't really complained.
Like I was, I was expecting people to complain a bit more, but like, no.
- Well, if you look at the PSF JetBrains survey,
the data science folks that side of the house
have definitely moved to Python 3 quicker and bigger
than the web team.
- I'm actually surprised how quickly people move up.
Like, you know, I don't know, even after 3.9 came out,
we've had people questing like,
"Oh my God, why does your annotation tool not work on 3.9?
"Or why does this not work?"
And it's like, "Nothing works on 3.9."
Or it's like, "LCI doesn't do 3.9 yet.
"Like, I can't build anything.
"None of our other packages run.
Like, sorry.
I felt like a big person developer for like the first time ever when I actually
got my first issue with running the latest and greatest Python, it was
because I was running GCP and I kept running into an error, running into an
error and I was like, you know what?
It used to work.
Let me just try it on three, eight, five, and then sure enough, it worked
perfectly and I was like, I've done it.
I've reached the new achievement.
Nice.
Yeah.
I've taken down the talk by then training website by shipping the
the walrus operator accidentally.
At the time, Ubuntu didn't support it.
A quick question or comment from
Zach in the comments
about when we can actually
say legacy Python's gone when the OS vendors
stop supporting it. Well, I think Python
2 is no longer shipping with the new Mac OS
and Canonical is starting to make
Python 3.8 the default.
So I think we're getting there.
I thought they were removing Python in general
from Mac OS and just making you
install it yourself.
I think there might be some internal system thing.
I saw people talking about the system Python 3.8,
even though I agree I heard the same thing you said.
But I don't have a fresh install.
- I think it's not actually such a bad idea.
Like I think, you know, for most things you do,
you have to install some extra stuff anyway.
So making it a more explicit install
from a user's perspective, I think, isn't even so terrible.
- Yeah.
- Because otherwise, you know, if you just type in Python,
you just run into all kinds of potential issues anyway.
So yeah.
- Yeah, especially when it's super out of date.
All right.
I end up telling people in my courses,
oh, you're using a Mac?
Yeah, ignore the Python that's installed.
I know this is a Python course.
Ignore the ones installed.
And here are ways that you can install it on your own
so it'll be up to date.
And here's how you can make sure it doesn't conflict
with what's already installed.
So maybe removing it all together
is not such a terrible thing.
- Yeah, for sure.
Homebrew, homebrew.
All right, Ines, the voting system has chosen you next.
- Unmute myself and look at my notes.
Yeah, so I think I've already mentioned the topic
I was going to talk about about five times so far,
but yeah, I think in 2020,
we really saw the ecosystem around type hints,
static type checking, types in general mature
and like really be widely adopted.
And I do think a part of that
is the more widespread adoption of Python 3
because before that, to be fair,
you could use type hints before Python 3
just for completeness,
but like that's not what people did
and it looked very, very different.
So yeah, now, and actually even I couldn't really
Imagine writing code without type-ins anymore.
Like if I write something and I'm not adding any types,
it feels kind of naked and it feels kind of wrong
and I actually feel like, oh my God,
I might be missing some issues here,
maybe I'm not catching some bugs.
So yeah, which is quite surprising,
but it says something considering I only just recently
was able to really embrace all the new Python 3 stuff.
- Yeah, that's a pretty quick transition.
Find it, yeah.
I depend on this thing now
that previously you had to stay away from.
Yeah, and I have static type checking enabled in Visual Studio Code.
It underlines things if you pass in the wrong types.
It gives you all these nice autocomplete prompts or previews if you want to.
That's also something I've gotten really, really used to over a really short period of time.
What about you, everyone? Do you use type pins?
Can we have an opinion, Paul?
Just raise the hand and then we summarize it for people who just--
- Everybody. - I might have to do it slowly.
I'm slowly starting to use them more and more as I see the advantages.
And in part, as I mentioned before, we started recording, like,
because my students are encouraging me to use it more and more because they want it,
because they come from languages where there's no such thing as optional type hints.
It's, you must do this or the program does not run.
So what do you know? They can actually be useful.
Yeah, I think that's one of the biggest benefits that I like about the type hinting system is that it's optional.
So you could choose to use it.
And then if you don't need it, and we could just take it out.
Because for me, I believe in being a lazy developer.
And stuff like type hints just make certain things a little bit more discoverable.
And kind of like what we were saying before, it just improves your tooling
to be able to discover more of your code for you.
I like to use it for APIs, especially for package interfaces,
so that people using a package can use the editor tools and stuff like that for the hints.
And also just wherever it makes sense.
I mean, if it looks like it actually distracts from readability,
then I take it out. Readability is above all for me.
So if it's usable and readable, it helps.
I mean, I wouldn't advocate any, like, I don't know,
if you have a function that takes several arguments and then returns, like, a callback
that gives you this kind of typing, I wouldn't advocate for that necessarily.
But yeah.
And I feel like they're working on some of that confusion as well,
and some of that, like, clutter and bloat.
I mean, that was, I talk about that 3.9 story.
It was because I was tired of typing, typing dot list or typing dot dict.
And it was like, Oh, you mean I can just do this now?
Like, and then sure enough, you know, stuff crashes and it's like, well, guess not maybe later, but
it's great that for people who are looking at Python as a tool that they're using,
not the language that they're writing on a day to day, but just flat out the tool that they're using.
They don't know what we're talking about half the time, but they can kind of look at something
and go, "STR, hmm.
Someone mentioned a string that one time. Maybe that's what that is."
You know, it's a lot easier than just looking at the code
and trying to figure it out.
Yeah, and speaking of tools, I think type-ins,
they're not only that syntax feature.
They've really enabled this whole new ecosystem of tools
that use type-ins to accomplish something else or in a creative way.
And I think many of them have been covered on this podcast previously.
For example, there's Pydantic, which uses type-ins
in actually one of my favorite creative ways for data validation, settings management.
It's actually a library we've adopted across a lot of our projects.
You just quickly, you know, you define this interface. Here's what I expect.
You get like, you know, kind of like JSON schema just with type hints.
- Identic is so wonderful. Yeah, you're right. It's really nice.
- Yeah, I would say it's one of my favorite recent discoveries in terms of Python developer tools.
And then of course, there's FastAPI and Typer developed by my colleague Sebastian,
which probably has been discussed a lot on this and related podcasts.
Yeah, he was on the show long ago, like 10 shows ago or so.
And yeah, that's a fantastic framework, too.
Yeah. So that's, I think it's also partly what really popular, popular, popularized,
great word, type hints in as a bot, I don't know, as a tool for, yeah, developing applications and
so on, I think also, also actually Pydantic. And yeah, we've also in 2020, I think, released our
So machine learning library think, which kind of functions more like an interface layer
and lets you write neural networks, combine layers written in different frameworks like
PyTorch, TensorFlow, and we've included custom types for arrays and all that stuff that passes
through the network.
Because if you're doing machine learning, a lot of it is really abstract.
You have this multidimensional array as in 300 dimensions, and then that goes through,
and then it gets transformed, and then that goes all the way back.
And at the end, you're hoping to get something out.
And there's a lot that can go wrong.
And it's not even about like, "Oh, how experienced are you as a programmer?"
It's like, that shit's just abstract.
And we can make it a bit less abstract, even by just providing custom types that you can
declare.
So it's easier to see what goes in, what comes out.
Do these layers fit together?
Do they not?
Because otherwise, yeah, you easily end up with these very hard to debug NumPy errors
triggered by like five layers deep that tell you that you can't broadcast that shape into
this other shape.
and you're like, yeah, that's gonna be fun.
- This doesn't help me, I have no idea.
Yeah, I think there's also things like mypyC,
which will compile stuff that has types,
and there's Cython, which will use the new Python type hints
to compile to much faster code.
So there's a lot of neat things coming out of it.
- Yeah, and I think especially also for abstract stuff
like machine learning, there are lots of use cases
that web type hints and type-based validation
is really promising, because we can also take something
a developer already knows, like typing your functions,
typing your layers, and it will just work
do some extra stuff if you wanted to.
Watching mypy evolve is really cool.
And for Think, we've briefly dabbled in my custom mypy plugins for a bit.
Like we have a plugin that checks if two layers you're chaining together
return the correct types.
Like, you know, if you have one layer that returns a two dimensional array of
floats and the other layer expects a two dimensional array of integers or four
dimensions, whatever, you can actually see that underlined in your editor done by
by mypy as you type the code.
So you can prevent a bug before you even make it,
like type it and introduce it.
So that's cool.
And I think that's all very actively developing.
So I think there's so much potential for custom plugins.
Like imagine more libraries just coming
with their own mypy plugins that help the developers
use those libraries better.
I think, yeah, that's all super cool.
- Yeah, it's early days and there's a bunch of great tools.
Cecil, let me round this out with,
coming back to one thing you said.
You talked about how it was optional.
- The closest analogy that I think we have to this
in other languages has got to be TypeScript,
which is like JavaScript plus types
and a little transpiling thing.
And it's all cool, but all my interactions with TypeScript
are like, oh, you haven't declared this thing right.
This thing's, it's like, it's as picky as C++ or C# or Java,
but it's not as like built from the start.
Like the tools aren't necessarily all there
to make that fit together.
So I always feel like I'm kind of stumbling over the things.
Like 80% of the time it's helped me
20% of the time that frustrates me.
Whereas like here, you can just kind of, you can leave it off, take it or
leave it if it's good, not good.
Yeah.
I think TypeScript definitely helped with some learnings about how developers
want to interact with typing.
I think the thing with TypeScript is it is very, like there's a lot of features
in there and it's very customizable, but you know, it's kind of like you have
like a nail, right?
And I gave you a jackhammer.
You really don't need the jackhammer.
Exactly.
So finishing hammer would be nice.
Yeah.
There's a lot of different things that you can customize.
And some people need that.
But I think for 90% of folks,
I'm making up that number, that's not a real number.
But for a lot of folks,
you probably don't need a lot of those knobs to turn and options to set.
Yeah, absolutely.
There was like a two-year period with TypeScript
where I'd read the roadmap.
They do a great job of running their project.
Great job.
But they put a feature in using words I didn't know from type theory.
And my answer was,
Oh, that's for Angular. Oh, that's for Angular. Oh, Angular is the only one having that problem.
There's some serious machinery.
Yeah, there is. All right. Final thought on this from the chat is Eric O'Shaughnessy says,
I love how typing solidifies the author's intent. Yeah. All right. Let's have the chooser choose again.
Jay.
All right. So I totally didn't peanut butter on this. But as y'all were talking, like, I just got some wonderful ideas.
And I immediately started thinking about just the doubling down of some of the technologies
that we've seen kind of pop up over the last couple of years, but then truly evolve.
And like one of the biggest examples of that, and I know I'm like five years, day, late,
dollar short here, but like Jupyter, anything Jupyter notebook related, like it's not just
for the solo data scientist anymore, like collaborative Jupyter notebooks, like to me
that I know people that just have dreams about that. And they're like the best dreams ever.
And, you know, I know, Mike, you just did a podcast episode a few weeks back about that.
And we were talking about it on Python Bytes a little bit. They're like, it's not just one
option anymore. It's, you know, there's Coke out there's PyBinder, there's DeepNote. Apparently,
I'm a DeepNote influencer, and I didn't even know it.
But that's awesome. You are bringing it up again.
But not just in like Jupyter land, we have like crazy ideas, like what if we could do Python on
the front end with anvil? And like now anvil is saying like, hey, we're going to open source some
of our server technology so that you can take this technology and do it yourself. And I think that
that's just like with type hints, we're coming up with these ideas, and we're taking them a step
further. I think that this is what, in my opinion, has kept me in the Python ecosystem as long as it
has is because I'm constantly learning about like brand new ways to do a thing
in Python. And I have to talk about this because I told people in my Slack
channel that I would, but like we just thought, you know, at Elastic, we just
launched a brand new tool called Elon and it's in beta. And the whole idea is
it's like a panda's data frame, but instead of storing all of your data in
memory, you can store it in an Elasticsearch, you know, data store.
Oh, that's an interesting idea.
So now instead of being limited to what your RAM can hold,
you're limited to how much space you got.
And you can run queries on it,
you can tie it into things like,
scikit-learn and TensorFlow and do machine,
any type of machine learning on it.
And at the end of the day,
you're doing transforms on the data
as it's in the data store.
So there's no more downloading a bunch of data,
working on it and trying to re-upload it.
And it's off of the backs of crazy ideas
from people crazier than I am that are just like,
"Hey, what if we could do this?"
And to me, that's all I wanted to do with Python
is just make up goofy stuff and see if it would work.
- I think that's an interesting idea.
You could start using things like lots of data
and things like serverless,
where you get really short execution times
and not much power.
But if it's already in something like Elastic,
you could do pandas against it,
like quote pandas, like the API against it.
without really suffering a lot of trying to download
a sheer little Docker Lambda callback thing
before it runs out of time to execute and whatnot.
- Yeah, I've actually, I think I've seen some people
do some cool stuff with spaCy and Elastic as well,
you know, processing all of, you know,
they're huge volumes of text,
which also I think is such an interesting part
of our application of data science.
Like, you know, you wanna have,
you have so much text that, you know,
you can't even, nobody can read it.
You can barely store it, but you can still analyze it
and process it and find something out about it
Otherwise, so yeah, that's not that actually sounds quite cool. I mean the problems I was I was having initially was just this amazing problem of like
I've got a million lines of data that I need to do something with and I've got this little Mac mini here
That's just chugging along trying its best and everyone's like well, why don't you just use the Google API and it's like, okay
Well, I did the math. I'm gonna need $20,000 and it's like, okay, so we can't use the Google API
We can't solve it with that problem. What else do we got and now it's like, oh wait
you mean I can just store all this data because I'm it's only a few gigs,
but then I can just hit my local server as many times as I want, let, you know, search store or
any type of data store that's good at retrieving the data as I want it as I need it and then let
it do its thing. Like that solved a $20,000 problem. I mean, even even aside from the cash,
do you want to send all your data to Google? Probably not. Yeah.
You can also send it to Facebook while you're at it.
I don't know. I was working with police call records,
so I don't want to send that data anywhere.
I don't want to be on a watch list.
No, exactly. I think those are like really,
a lot of these really important applications of the technology
in the health domain, people are doing good and useful stuff,
but they should not do that stuff at that type of cost,
which means sharing all of their sensitive data with companies
that will, you know, want it for some other reason.
Yeah, absolutely.
Matt, Ruven, you guys do training.
What's the Jupyter story around there?
- I did a class with, not Jupyter,
but it was all Colab based this morning.
So yeah, I use it a lot.
I think it's great for beginners.
Like I said, for a lot of people
who are scientists or engineers,
that's what they sort of consider Excel.
And so a lot of them sort of want to sit in Jupyter all day.
They don't even want to like think about modules or code
or even software engineering, right?
And so it's somewhat of a challenge for me to sort of say, okay, let's talk about some
engineering skills and some good best practices for Python projects. And I'm like, I don't want
to leave Jupiter, right? Can I do this all in Jupiter? I'm like, well, you could, but you kind
of don't want to per se. But yeah, definitely cool. I think what I'd love to see is Inez's
fancy mypy checker hooked up with pandas on Jupiter, that would make my day, because that's
That's one of the things that I find confuses people
just with pandas having 50 ways to do things
and then objects returning five different types
or methods that return five different types.
You don't get any tab completion
or any of that good stuff in Jupyter
when you're doing a lot of the machine learning stuff.
- Yeah, and a bunch of grown-up engineering stuff
is coming to Jupyter, right?
Like NBDev, NBQA, some of these other stuff
that's coming there is making it
way more interesting for that regard.
Yeah, the MV dev stuff is interesting. Just coming. I mean, that's sort of taking it to that sort of literate style of programming where we're going to stay in Jupiter all day and do everything from that. And then, you know, Netflix has their stuff where they're deploying Jupiter notebooks to production.
Yeah, it was paper mill. Yeah. Reuben, how about you? And then I'm gonna run the chooser.
I use Jupyter every day for my training.
I don't use slides, I just do live coding.
I find that's a great way to show them,
not just the answer,
this is how you code something,
but this is the process you use to get to the solution.
Because teaching people that process is really important.
It also means I can share with them
everything that I typed during the day really, really easily.
People are a little resistant to using it first,
especially experienced developers.
They're like, "Wait, what is this thing?
Why are you not using a normal IDE?"
I've actually forced myself in the last year to remember, "Oh yeah, we should do a few
exercises and tell them to use the IDE so they won't think that everything is done in
Jupyter."
That's a great environment, but there are other ways to develop software.
Why does Python only run in this weird web browser thing?
Right, right, exactly.
Speaking of this, I think this is another reason why Python has taken off so much, just
that you want stuff to be dynamic.
If you're doing the sort of data science-y type of work, you want to run your code that
even if you're running it in an IDE in a more traditional way.
But I think Jupyter has especially...
Not just like, "Oh, you want to have these little notebook cells in your browser,"
but more like, "This is the type of way you want to interact with code.
Run something, change a line, run again, run that part."
Well, that's where they're coming from, too.
They're coming from notebook environments.
And so this makes sense for a lot of these people.
And being able to just explain it on the same...
Just in one look.
Like, instead of going, "Here's five slides explaining what I'm about to do,"
or here's just the code.
Now let me sit here and explain it to you.
I can literally break it down line by line.
Okay, this is what's about to happen now.
Let's run this and watch it happening as we go.
For people who don't write Python full-time,
again, it's amazing because for them,
they can see it piece by piece, just like, you know,
my daughter, I'm just trying to teach her how to read early
and it's just like, break it up piece by piece.
And like, you can do that when you're training
young experience-wise Pythonistas and just say,
like, hey, let's just look at what this does.
And if we want to dig into it,
it's almost like having a debugger in your presentation
and just being able to like stop at any point in time
and go, all right, let's jump in, let's go deeper,
let's really talk about this.
- Yeah, or be able to step back two lines
of in your execution.
- True.
- All right, just for the time being.
- I started using.
- Go ahead, last thought, Reuven,
you get the final thought on this one.
- I started using more and more markup
in my notebooks as well to like,
sort of document what I'm doing explicitly
and sort of instead of just using hashtags and comments.
So it becomes much more obvious with bullet points.
I think people are enjoying that as well.
- Yeah, that's great.
And that's, I mean, that's part of the Zen of notebooks.
All right.
And you're up next, the random match choices selected you.
- Okay, so my big story for this year is very small story,
a Microsoft story.
It's COVID, it's the coronavirus,
which I think for the first time ever,
it's the topic that everyone is speaking about
in every country, every walk of life.
Like whoever I talk to, wherever they are,
this is the only thing people talk about
because it is such a profound effect
on everything we've done.
Now, you know, this is a Python show,
so we'll talk about the Python aspect of it.
And I'm not trying to minimize at all
the extraordinary pain that people are going through
physically, medically, emotionally, financially,
on, on, and on.
But Python has continued sort of chugging along
throughout this crisis.
In fact, we've seen that big companies,
high-tech companies are actually among the winners in this
as the whole world has gone digital.
And companies are hiring Python developers.
They're increasingly desperate for Python developers.
The number of people in my corporate training classes,
who when we go around and everyone introduces themselves,
who were hired in the last six months, is amazing to me.
Like, these are people who are working from home,
were interviewed from home, hired from home,
and are now doing training from home
as their companies sort of grow in interest
and power and everything.
So people who have Python skills
have continued to be, I would even say, are increasingly in demand, which is amazing.
The bad news, or among the bad news, is, of course, so I mentioned this before, PyCon,
and all the other meetings and meetups and gatherings have suffered as a result.
The good news on this front is I've been able to speak at many more conferences than I would have been able to
because, hey, I can attend the conference from my home office. I don't need to fly anywhere, go anywhere.
But you know what? All of these conferences, these online solutions are still really lacking.
At the end of the day, as much as we want to say,
we're virtual, we're online, we communicate this way.
And that is an important part of things,
that face-to-face contact,
that personal contact is really missing.
And I'm really feeling it.
I've only been going to conferences for a few years now,
and boy, I really miss being in the same room
as other people and talking to them and chatting
and just sort of randomly bumping into people.
And then you also have the financial aspect of it
that someone was mentioning earlier, the PSF,
their big fundraiser each year is Python.
And I'm sure it was a hit for them,
not just not to have it this year,
but to have to cancel the venue.
And I am extremely skeptical that's going to happen in person.
I know EuroPython already said it's not happening in 2021.
And we'll have to see exactly how this affects the community going forward.
I'd say so far we're doing okay,
but here's an opportunity for something to figure out
how can we do conferences online that are effective in a closer way
to what we've been doing so far.
The news is, I would say, on balance good for Python
and for people who know Python,
but still pretty bad overall.
And I'll also add that these vaccines, I mean, boy, oh, boy.
If they work, this is going to be like--
not as a biologist or anything, but I'm
so amazingly impressed with all the science and the work
that people have been doing on this front.
And I think this has a chance also
to affect their lives moving forward, how they develop them.
They just need to make a PyCon bubble.
So in the United States, the NBA was
continuing to play because they had a bubble where
they isolated all the players for however long, right?
So we just all go to somewhere and bubble up for however long.
- Then we can have our conference.
- I'll isolate with you guys for a month, absolutely.
- I don't know if my family will let me do that.
- Jay, we'll just do it in San Diego, man.
It's nice there.
- Okay, I'm all for it.
- Coronado Island, we'll just get a section of it, okay?
- Yeah.
- But no, mandatory quarantine for like conferences.
I just did two week quarantine here
to be able to enter Australia.
- Yeah, just put an Australian.
- And I can just chill around in the hotel room
for two weeks and then you're free.
- Icon in Australia.
- That sounds okay to me.
- Problem solved.
- Well, I mean, to be fair, it's expensive.
So I wouldn't, you know, it's like, you know,
would you want to pay like, you know,
your conference plus two weeks at a hotel
in order to do that?
I don't think that'd be even less inclusive
than a lot of these conferences already are, so.
- I don't want to take all of his thunder,
but one of the first conferences that I watched was,
Cecil, please remind me now, 'cause I'm blanking.
That's how long of a year it's been.
the conference that you helped put on and the Juneteenth.
Yeah.
And, and with that, I mean, one great conference, I'm sorry, I screwed up on remembering the
name.
That's my fault, not yours.
But also the sheer fact that that conference was organized in two weeks, and it was an
amazing conference, like the ability.
That could never have been done if it was in person, right?
Yes.
So like the accessibility that you're providing to new speakers, people that normally would
not be able to get up and give a presentation. I've had that conversation so many times of, like,
the type of talks that I like to create are not the type of talks you see at PyCon,
and there's a reason why. And it's not a bad thing. It's just it is what it is.
And I think when you're able to say, you know what, let's do a conference. Let's make this
happen. Let's just get up. We can have fun with it. I've seen some conference talks that were
literally small budget films. They had multiple casts. I've done transcriptions on conference
talks that literally had... They gave me the script and said, "All right, here you go."
So when you can actually do things like that and think outside the box and use this time
to readjust the needle... There was a good podcast episode on More Than Just Code, I believe. Not
More Than Just Code. I don't remember what it is. I'll find it. Greater Than Code. That's what it
was. And they said, "If we haven't taken this time to do something better when things are different,
when things have improved, then shame on all of us because yes, this sucked, but it caused us to
think so much outside the box that we should be able to take all that knowledge with us when we
can get back in the box and just have a ton of fun with it." Yeah, I think a lot of opportunities
have been made available for people to attend conferences and for people to get jobs where
companies would previously say, no, you have to move to San Francisco or to Omaha or whatever.
It's like, well, you know what? No one's going in the office. Let's try hiring from the best
in the world instead of the best in Nebraska or whatever.
I think that might be the biggest fallout of this, Michael, is just the change in everything
being centrally located in Silicon Valley.
Yeah. I've heard of a lot of people like that actually just have jobs in the valley that
have moved back to where their parents are because it's like 10 times cheaper or something
like that and they're not going to want to move back.
Have you heard that some companies have been readjusting their salaries?
They're saying, "Well, if you live outside of the Bay Area, then it's cheaper, so we're
going to cut your salary as a result."
Yeah, but people have always been doing that.
That's like, unfortunately, not new.
So if you're listening and this happens, you can say, "Well, you no longer have to pay
$18 million for my office area, so let's call it an even swap."
(laughing)
- Just keep a virtual address in the Bay Area.
- Exactly, my PO box is right down on Fifth Street.
All right, last one, this random choice was easy
'cause we're down to our final excellent guest.
Matt Harrison, what do you got for us?
- Okay, my thought was just on sort of the hardware aspect
of things this year.
So I have a daughter who started college this year
for better or for worse,
and she's learning both C++ and Python right now,
her linear algebra class as a Python lab, which I think is awesome.
I wish I had that.
But I was actually helping her with some homework.
I wasn't doing it, but she was like, "I can't figure this out."
So I was her rubber duck the other night.
And her issue was allocating memory, right?
And so one of the things that's nice about Python
is you don't have to worry about allocating memory.
She got all the output, but she was just double freeing a pointer here,
which they checked on submission.
So pythons now now we're seeing python and i'll just tie this like I have a client who wants
Next year wants me to do a training on gpus with python
Which just goes to show like my clients tend to be big companies and so big companies are now leveraging like specialized technology
To do things very quickly, right? And if you have a gpu you can get ten hundred thousand times performance
that you get out of a CPU.
So I think that's super exciting.
There's the Rapids project,
which is heavily sponsored by Nvidia.
And I'm super impressed with that.
They're basically like taking well-known APIs
and basically saying,
hey, your code basically change an import
or with the change of an import and this hardware,
your code will run X times faster or whatever.
And so I think that's super compelling and exciting,
Not that necessarily everyone will have access to those sorts of things,
but it's now getting to the point where it's becoming more common.
On the note of hardware, I think another thing that was really
interesting this year was the Apple M1 chip coming out.
I actually bought a beefy PC this year, having run a MacBook for 15 years,
just because due to Corona and whatnot, I needed something beefy to start doing
virtual sharing and presentation like this, and my MacBook just wasn't cutting it.
But the thing I don't like about my PC is that it has,
it sounds like it's gonna take off
every time I start doing something, right?
Like modern Intel chips can take us to Mars if they want to.
We just need to like make a huge drone out of them.
And so I'm super excited to see,
like if you can get a silent MacBook that, you know,
is super powerful, runs faster than Intel chips,
that's super compelling,
especially if they allow you to get a little bit more RAM,
which from the machine learning side is interesting to me.
But I'm also excited about the competition factor of that.
I think like Intel and the chip set is sort of stagnated
for the past couple of years,
we've sort of run out of the end of Moore's law per se.
So I think both the GPU and the M1,
it'll be interesting to see what the competition is
from the PC manufacturers,
if they're going to do a similar everything on a chip thing
just sort of go with what they've been going with.
I think competition is good.
And so I'm excited that Apple did this, even though there's going to be some growing pains
and Python might have some issues at first, but I think in the end, new technologies,
new hardware that allow us to write at high levels and not have to worry about freeing
and allocating memory, which again, a lot of people are using Python, don't care about
that.
They don't want to be programmers.
They want to leverage great code, stand on the shoulders of giants and the latest and
and greatest software and hardware and have it be fast.
So I'm super excited about the future with them.
Yeah, I'm really excited about both these things.
Like the whole GPU revolution is incredible.
And the Apple M1 stuff is going to be really, really interesting.
Like, like you, I, I bought it maxed out Mac mini actually had already
ordered a top of the line MacBook pro 16 inch, and then that came out.
I started seeing the reviews.
I'm like, you know what?
Forget it.
I'm not getting that thing.
I'm getting this new one to try it out.
And he does have some drawbacks,
like Docker doesn't work right away.
Maybe it will, maybe it won't.
But I have a 2018 MacBook Pro that's pretty good.
I have a SimRacing 16 core machine over there.
Like, I've got plenty of Intel stuff to work.
So I'm gonna try to jump on this.
And I think the interesting Python angle here,
besides just having stuff to run our code in,
is, you know, Enos talked about like,
her CI didn't support 3.9 right away.
Well, whose CI is gonna build wheels
for Apple M1 straight away and things like that?
There's going to be some interesting growing pains, especially on the data
science side, as this true platform.
Yeah.
It's fun.
You mentioned that because actually, yeah, when this came out, we were also
thinking like, ah, maybe we should get one of these, you know, we want to make
sure spacey compiles properly on it and we can really, you know, optimize for that.
And did you guys go on?
Yeah, because someone has to do it or so, you know, not yet.
No.
Also it's a bit difficult with the traveling, but like, yeah, that's kind of.
When we have other priorities too, this is not, I wouldn't put this like at the
very top, but like, it's definitely something you want to do, but at the same
At the same time, we also want to keep optimizing for CPU.
Like, that's the other thing.
Of course, you know, even all these new NLP models,
all of that stuff obviously runs great on a GPU,
and we'll see a lot of improvements,
and we also see this become much more available
and cheaper for people to use.
But at the same time, we're still optimizing
our tools and libraries for CPU.
Like, you can run it on your random laptop,
and also it's still, for a long time,
it will be cheaper still.
If you just, you know, you want to run lots of machines,
and you can get those, you know, much cheaper in the cloud.
And if you can parallelize, you can train your models very efficiently on CPU, if you can get it to work.
That will always be cheaper for a long time.
There's a lot to say about just the overall cost of computing as a whole.
I mean, this is great. This is $10.
And I mean, I can run a lot of stuff on that.
You're holding up a circuit, an Adafruit thing just for the people who are not on the video.
Oh, yeah, sorry. I'm holding a Raspberry Pi Zero W.
So it's like, you know, four gigs of RAM, like enough, you can buy a 64 gig, like
flash drive for $3 now, like it's amazing.
Like just the overall cost of compute has dropped so much.
I mean, what was it?
The, what is the Raspberry Pi?
400 where it's, it's just, it looks like a keyboard, but it's
actually a whole computer.
Yeah.
So it's like, as we continue to do more and more, we're doing it with less and
less and it's cheaper and cheaper and cheaper. And most of us are coming from some place where
the cost of living is too damn high. And we're able to say that we can afford to buy a $15 Pi
Zero and not think about it too hard. But the fact that we're getting to that point where you
can have people all over the world where the question isn't anymore, how do I get a computing
device in my hands? It's like, okay, now I have some choices and they're all affordable. Like to
me that's we're going to see a lot of things come where Brian Okken is right now where VS
2103 is in the future. There's gonna be a lot of great things coming. Yes, I'm looking at chat.
I have my kids to have one of those one laptop per child in their bedroom over there, right,
which I think that the Raspberry Pi 400 is sort of, it's the next gen of that. It's actually
something that makes sense. Everyone has a TV, right? And you can just plug it in and you're
You're not in some weird, I mean, you're in Linux,
so yeah, you're in a weird environment, but you can run--
- Is that one of the laptops with the hand crank on it?
- Well, it has the little wings.
Mine didn't have the hand crank, but--
- Okay.
- I actually, like, I kept hearing about Raspberry Pi,
and so I decided to order one recently,
and I haven't done anything with it.
It just came a few days ago.
But I'm looking at this thing, I'm like,
oh my God, this little card here
that cost me less than $100, a lot less than that,
is more powerful than the computer I use
to run my entire business for years,
and years and years.
It's just astonishing to me.
- Yeah, so I think that's probably a good place
to round out the show.
Like, the future is so exciting,
and in some ways we're kind of living there, right?
Some of these things that are coming out are so amazing.
And I just want to say thank you all,
to you all for being here.
You're all doing such amazing work,
and it's really humbling.
You all took time from crazy schedules,
from traveling, from weird locations,
to just be here and make this whole event happen.
Thank you for listening to Python Bytes.
Follow the show on Twitter via @PythonBytes.
that's Python Bytes as in B-Y-T-E-S.
And get the full show notes at pythonbytes.fm.
If you have a news item you want featured,
just visit pythonbytes.fm and send it our way.
We're always on the lookout for sharing something cool.
On behalf of myself and Brian Aukin,
this is Michael Kennedy.
Thank you for listening and sharing this podcast
with your friends and colleagues.